[Musik]
hallo willkommen die trends hat
versprochen dass ich immer mal wieder
videos zeigen vom fortschritt und
verbaut und bei uns geht es los heute
werden die steine geliefert und dann
gehts mit dem bauern lose fundament
liegt nämlich schon und ich werde euch
jetzt immer mal wieder zeigen wie weit
wissen was alles klappt auch nicht so
gut klappt und hier im hintergrund seht
ihr auch unser baustellen da sieht man
nur im groben mal das gebäude und wie
das am ende ungefähr aussehen soll und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie die steine
angeliefert werden und dann legen wir
los
[Musik]
jung
morgens 8 uhr knapp über sieben grad für
mich also sollten auch der küche ist
natürlich sehr kalt aber die sonne kommt
kraftvoll zugleich wärme und ich werde
dann die kälte gewöhnen
und heute werden jetzt die bauern
gemacht also das heißt vor ein paar
tagen ist die bodenplatte gegossen
worden und heute fangen wir an mit dem
bauern später besuch immer noch die
moral hier hinter mir ist unser peter
verrührt es hier gleich den cannes war
wie gemacht für merkel rührte an für die
erste lack und ich gucke jetzt mal kurz
zu und am tag immer alle mir dann
erzählt die küchenmaschine der baustelle
oder kurze frage geht auf 1 bis holland
für die künste kleber an
kein flugzeug wieder heim weil für die
küchenmaschine muss man aufpassen und
ganz langsam anfangen
[Musik]
es reicht cremig gerührt bei
schlagermusik netz
[Musik]
und sauber machen
experte peter hier die erste hilft das
ist auch ganz wichtig dass die ganz
gerade wird das ist ja wie beim torten
backen und torten stapeln wenn man die
erste sichtung liefert wir die ganze
torte kommt deswegen bereits über den
täter der papa auch nicht mehr haben
schon mal bei uns im badezimmer die
mauer hochgezogen und die wahlleiter
schließen wir gedacht das mache die
hälfte aber gleich mit und wir benutzen
36 5 bauer weg für die außenwände puma
die steine
[Musik]
natürlich viele verschiedene steine die
man zum bauern verwenden kann aber
natürlich ihre vor und nachteile und der
unterdrückung entschieden weil für uns
einfach die besten eigenschaften haben
briefe fotos von außen es nochmal
isolieren von dämmen das isoliert von
ganz alleine weil da ganz viele kleine
lufteinschlüsse print sind unterstein da
ist schön groß wir sehen uns auch hier
das geht wirklich super schnell und in
wenigen tagen kann man auch ein kleines
familienhaus wirklich hoch bauen
die steine sind groß aber eben nicht zu
schwer also ich kann sie auch selber
hochnehmen und tragen und bei den fans
so vorstellen
sie werden unter druck im dampf aus die
härte aber das sehen was später wenn
murat bei der arbeit besuchen die kämpfe
jetzt hier noch ein bisschen mit
und ihr könnt dabei zugucken
[Musik]
nicht
so jetzt bin ich fertig für heute und
werden 66 verloren also sozusagen das
geschirrspülmaschine gibt sie nämlich
nicht
und dann werden wir gleich den mut hat
bei der arbeit versuchen damit ihr alle
man sehen können was arbeitet dieser
mann eigentlich acht stunden am tag mit
frag ich mich auf die ganze zeit und ab
und sahen wie die steine hergestellt
werden und da laufen wir einfach nur ich
nur abzocke muss ich nicht
[Musik]
hier informierten schlager du hast hier
werden alle steine gelagert und ich
könnte hier auch mal unterschied zeigen
also dieser seien hier in richtung
verwenden wir für unsere aufwände und
hier auf meiner linken seite seht ihr
den stein den der bub herstellt er
arbeitet von ist hier im werk aber dem
kalksandstein städte auch her
der mittelschwere und vom herstellung
von bewährten beide steine ziemlich
ähnlich wie komisch ist aber so
[Applaus]
neue formel 1
ja
leider
sparbuch apple
[Musik]
die cds die fertigen steine und da
gibt's natürlich verschiedene formate
das für jeden bedarf aus andere
wir haben hier den 36 5 aus stein
missbräuche vorstellen wird größer dass
stein um für mehr luft einen schlüssel
umso mehr wärme kann isolieren und
natürlich die größe des sein und vorher
kann ich frauen ihr kind da
wahrscheinlich von den lego ist und
jemand bauen kann wenn man mit ganz
kleinen steinen baut kann man nur so
hohen turm bauen
und wenn man die größeren steinen kann
man eben viel höher bauen wo ich es hier
eben auch und was ich ganz toll kinder
ist das mal den stein denn ganz einfach
auf der baustelle bearbeiten kann
er sei wirklich sehr handlich und nicht
wer also den blick auf add hoch und vor
allem kann man ihnen richtig gut zu
sehen und beim euro das ist auch ganz
einfach den fotos sieht man hier nut und
feder das heißt hier diese glut und dann
kommt eben jeder also das passende
gegenstück und ich zeig euch jetzt mal
wie man dem ganz einfach zusehen kann
arbeitslos
befreit sozusagen die elektrische tor
zuwege zuerst wir die mischung an
gemacht und die zutaten bleiben
verbunden
die zutaten verhütung zu den
wesentlichen die natürlichen rohstoffe
sei mit kalk und wasser kurz bevor der
teig in die kassen form gefüllt wird
kommt der printsektor und das könnt ihr
euch so vorstellen der poren
wildfütterung ist sowie die hefe im
hefeteig und lässt die masse gut
ausgehen hier blicke ganz gut mit die
masse aufgeht die kastenform weiter bis
zur hälfte gefüllt und jetzt bildet sich
diese vielen poren und es dauert etwa 40
bis 45 minuten
diese poren sorgen dann am ende für die
isolierung und die wärmedämmung von
achtung nicht zusätzlich gedämmt werden
muss während dieser zeit wird die mache
auch formstabilen wird aus dem anschluss
geschnitten werden kann
und im gegensatz zum kuchen wird
ungeschnitten bevor er in den stein hat
der kette kommen
an dieser stelle kommt die masse ist auf
der kastenform heraus und wird mit hilfe
von geräten zurecht geschäft ähnlich wie
bei meiner torten pflege sind hier ganz
viele drähte welche die formstabiler
masse zu einzelnen steigern
zurechtschneiden die anfallenden reste
werden dann der übung herstellung wieder
zugeführt
in
[Musik]
diese stein hätte kettl sind ähnlich wie
ein dampfkochtopf in der küche
darin werden die steine die jetzt noch
ein zweig sind und welche man mit den
händen verdrücken könnte ausgehärtet
nach dem out prozess sind sie so viel
davon da wird eben heute braucht haben
[Musik]
und dass dieser junge mann hier arbeitet
macht der buch hat den ganzen tag im
kalksandsteinwerk
[Musik]
berlin
dies seien hätte gestern prüfungsformen
spektakulär aus arbeitet um 36 meter
lange ich könnte darin ein 36 meter
langes werk etwas bei der verpackung
erhalten die eltern paletten zum schluss
die typische folierung wenn sie die
steine schritt von der produktion bis
hin zur baustelle und auch bei der
verpackung mit um gut gearbeitet
die steine werden in umweltfreundliche
pe folie eingeschweißt
[Musik]
und wo kann dann am ende das haus
aussehen
ihr seht ihr ein kleines musste heute
hat schwabe drauf geschrieben und wäre
im prinzip jetzt auch wie hier das
außenmauerwerk aus ytong gemacht und die
innenwände werden wir ein bisserl anders
machen es zeige sich aber das nächste
mal und das kleine musste heute nehme
ich mit für die radler durch ihre barbie
reinpassen vollzogen wieder zurück auf
dem bau ist sondern die männer haben
fleißig gearbeitet und die mauern sind
schon etwas höher aber laut sega
mitgebracht damit etwas schneller
arbeiten können und das war es
eigentlich schon heute vom bau ich werde
die nächsten wochen natürlich noch
weiter informieren wie es hier läuft und
wie es vorangeht
ich werde übrigens im januar auf der
baumesse seien in münchen und war am 21
januar da bin ich dann auch für euch da
ich werde da beim stand von stella übung
sein und zwar von 11 bis 13 uhr und ich
werde eure bücher signieren
autogrammkarten widmet oder auch einfach
fotos mit euch machen und mit mich mit
euch gerne über den bau austauschen oder
auch übers kochen backen das geht
natürlich auch aber mittlerweile bin ich
dass ein kleiner bauexperte geworden und
ich freue mich das schon richtig arg auf
euch und als überraschung habe ich für
euch 200 freikarten organisiert ihr
könnt ihr jetzt gerne bei mir gewinnen
und zwar einfach die ersten 100 die eine
e mail an dieser eingeblendete e mail
adresse schreiben gewinnen jeweils zwei
karten
michael zeuch nur darum bitten dass sich
die patienten die auch wirklich kommen
möchten wenn ich sehr hart um die karten
gekämpft und ja dass wir dann eben auch
auf jeden fall vorbei kommen könnte was
wollt ihr noch sagen im prinzip was ist
eigentlich schon vom bau ich werde euch
natürlich dem nächsten auch weiterhin
über die fortschritte informieren und
werde mich jetzt mal gleich um den wald
kümmern also bis zum nächsten mal sieht
man die mauer ist für 180 gebaut oder
kelly kelly kelly
sally
er verbringt hat wissen auf der
baustelle die sich in der küche du musst
mir helfen bringen mit dem model jetzt
kommt jetzt